and our theme for the hour is out of
control it's all about sort of the
monopolies that are emerging among tech
giants it's been about 20 years now and
since John Perry Barlow wrote his
declaration of an independent cyberspace
that was of a manifesto written and
delivered from Switzerland in 1996 in
which you would say things like you know
on in cyberspace we are bodyless
creatures you know our laws you're the
laws of governments cannot touch us here
we are immaterial shapeshifters who will
operate civically and politically in
completely new forms now has that sort
of early promise of the internet really
borne fruit I'll begin by introducing
our speakers for today so to my right is
James Williams he is an award-winning
Oxford researcher and he has previously
worked at Google for over ten years so
this will prove some fascinating
insights I'm sure David Aaronovitch
times columnist and BBC broadcaster and
to my far left is Margaret Heffernan
entrepreneur CEO and author and I think
we'll begin with James Williams how
dangerous are the tech giants I guess it
depends on if you're standing on their
shoulders or not yeah no I mean I I
think there's a lot of types of bigness
that that you know we we tend to talk
about when we talk about monopolies
there's kind of the size of you know
companies having control over certain
market this kind of typical way we talk
about it the way I think about what's
happening right now is that the kind of
bigness that matters the kind of
monopoly that matters is the monopoly
that a lot of these large technology
technology companies have over our
attention over our or mind over the
decisions we make day-to-day so we're of
course not their customers right we're
their product we're the kind of the raw
resource that that they extract and I
think what we're starting to realize at
this point in the evolution of the
internet is that the
has actually been the the case that
we've been trading our attention for
these quote-unquote free products and
that these companies have gotten very
very good at extracting our attention at
punching exactly the right ones in our
brains to get us to you know do what
they want to do they want us to do think
what they want us to think these
platforms by and large to the extent
that you know we're talking about
advertising platforms here which I think
we mostly are when we talk about like
Google Facebook Twitter they're there
persuasion machines and so I think it's
a kind of monopoly on attention a
monopoly on persuasion and so you know
if if in our own lives or in as society
doing what matters requires first giving
attention to the things that matter I
think that what these companies have a
monopoly on is a kind of first order you
know public good in a way it's kind of
the essential thing that you know the
lens through which we see the world and
so and I think we're starting to see the
biases of these media the biases that
these platforms represented and all
sorts of things in our politics and our
personal lives and our social lives so
so you know whether dangerous is the
right word or not I don't know but I
think there's certainly a type of power
that I think is is fundamentally new in
human history both in kind and in scale
so so yeah I think it's certainly a type
of power worth being concerned about and
worth taking seriously and worth
ultimately reforming and bringing under
some kind of democratic control okay
thank you so yeah here we have this
question of sort of what is it about the
tech monopoly that is different and
perhaps more invasive and on it on new
sort of unprecedented scales David let's
turn to you know how dangerous are the
tech giants in your view first let's
just kind of reflect upon where we've
come and how quickly we've come there in
2011 we were saluting the Arab Spring as
being a product of the technological
revolution in 2018 the dominant
narratives fuck-off Alexa essentially
and that's an incredibly fast period of
time to have gone from one set of
convictions to another about what has
become verily the V the central new
technology of our existences so let's
just reflect a bit on what was good
Google for instance the Google search
engine is the most useful advance for
journalists and researchers invented in
my lifetime
Bar None it's much better than libraries
were far better than libraries were far
more efficient when I started journalism
we had a thing called a cuttings library
you'd put a request in to the cuttings
library on Monday and on Friday you'd
get back the best 25 searches that you
could get on the subject that you were
talking about so it's in many ways it's
transformative and one of the things
that helped that transformation was the
fact that the tech companies doing it
were operating by and large under that
were American companies operating under
the American First Amendment in other
words they weren't subject to the
constant series of restrictions or
freedom of speech and expression which
other countries large countries would
place upon their citizens China and
Russia and so on and I suppose we
thought naively that sooner or later
countries like China Russia Iran some
would follow suit and there and would
actually be forced by the internet and
by and by what the tech giant's were
doing by and large beneficially to open
up and to democratize those the virtues
and the easiness of the of the of those
tech companies are still true most of
them are still true and if you want an
alternative let's say to how they allow
people to do things then just think
about what you're able to do and what
you're not able to do in China and
what's bad about it of course is firstly
that that very cacophony created a kind
of Wild West it's what often what it's
called online which people then found
incredibly uncomfortable in some cases
dangerous and wanted
to try and deal with secondly the
economics of it completely disrupted the
economics of all kinds of other
situations in my own business for
instance it wiped out newspaper owns are
certainly seeing quite a lot of
television advertising main revenue
streams simply disappeared and went into
the endless more of Google and Facebook
and other another place and these
companies were unaccountable for the
fact that this was happening nobody
could do anything about it and nobody
could alter it um the other thing about
it was that they were operating
according to their own rules now insofar
as those were First Amendment rules they
could be thought to be good but quite a
lot of people gypped against that not
least the European countries of the
European Union and so on who felt that
the idea of an American giant
effectively telling you what you could
search for and what you couldn't in
other words the power of the Google
algorithm an algorithm I suspect is a
world boy here quite a lot today and so
I've gone too far now the question for
us is how do we maintain what's good
about all that whilst losing what's bad
about that without also affecting
freedom of speech and expression more
widely
that's our dilemma the idea that there
is a simple way through this
they were good once they're bad now not
on the head I think is problematic okay
thank you very much
and Margaret you'd like to address this
question how dangerous of the tech
giants in your VM it was really
interesting as you were doing your your
introduction I was reminded to when I
started my first internet business in
the 90s it was exactly that Golden Age
you know and it was a whole bunch of
rather strange maverick people doing
something just to see what we could do
right and it was very very striking and
super noticeable that at some point it
became clear that among all the other
cool stuff we could do we could make a
ton of money at which point a whole new
population descended upon us you know I
had people in ties applying for jobs I
mean it was mind-blowing because they
were really different with really
different motives yeah and you know so I
suspect now we'd say that's
my end of the transition from Internet
1.0 to 2.0 and I don't know where we are
now but it definitely it changed it
changed from a kind of really kind of
funky niche experiment to something
whose scale we didn't appreciate but
definitely some people appreciated the
potential economic scale that was
involved I think you know there are a
couple of things I would say about this
one is I think what you're seeing from
the tech companies themselves is a
really epic scale of bystander behavior
right there are a lot of companies
running around saying something must be
done
nobody iced by somebody out there right
so we recognize there are problems but
they're not our problems they're bigger
than us so they're not ours and I heard
the CEO of Amazon UK the other day say
you know we think GD propios marvellous
and what a shame it wasn't earlier what
a shame government isn't doing more
because we think of a real framework
would economically be better but then
they don't do a thing except carry on
collecting data and using it and proudly
announcing that people who have alexa's
buy more toothpastes through Amazon so
that's great they figured out a terrific
incredibly complicated way to sell
toothpaste but you know but it's not
their problem
[Applause]